ladies ladies we made a show
we did it we did a show we made a show
and it's out in the world
time in a very difficult time and you
wrote a great song for it sarah
i did write a great song you really did
very very inspired by all of you truly
this is a song about being perfectly
imperfect
and uh the more we can embrace that i
think the more fun we're all gonna have
i agree right so this one's called four
star
yay
[Music]
we're gonna start fresh take a couple
new steps
and wear our comfortable shoes these are
comfortable at barbecue
[Music]
the problem here was you
take off the filter from the photograph
and look who
it is you see
it isn't perfect so what's wrong with
that the best things in life
are free that's why rich people never
carry wallets
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
up
i may not be stronger than the best
but i got a diamond turd inside my chest
i've got a lot to learn
i don't regret it women
[Music]
like delicious
[Music]
[Music]
we might fly
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh we are four stars guys we are
literally four stars
you